Welcome, everyone, to
CIFAR's series of virtual talks
and today's conversation
with Stephen Reicher.
These online talks are intended
to showcase our research
conducted by CIFAR's fellows
can help inform decision making
as governments develop policies
to reopen shuttered
societies and economies
in the wake of COVID-19.
If you're not familiar with us,
CIFAR is a Canadian-based
global research organization
that convenes extraordinary minds
from around the world to address some
of the most important questions
facing science and humanity.
Like many other organizations,
CIFAR has pivoted quickly
to take action on COVID-19,
launching new projects and initiatives,
some of which we're highlighting
through this series.
My name is Kate Geddie.
I'm a senior director
of research at CIFAR,
and it's my pleasure to introduce you
to Professor Stephen Reicher today.
Steve is a professor of psychology
at the University of St. Andrews
and a leading authority
on social psychology.
His work focuses on
questions of social identity,
collective behavior, crowd
behavior, and leadership.
And he is a fellow
in CIFAR's new Boundaries,
Membership, & Belonging research program.
In recent months, Steve has served
on behavioral science advisory
groups to both the Scottish
and UK governments
concerning the responses
to the COVID-19 pandemic.
And despite how busy
that must have kept him,
he has amazingly managed
to coauthor a book
that was published in late May,
titled "Together Apart: The
Psychology of COVID-19."
Given the intense interest
in this topic then and now,
it was published at that time online
as an uncorrected proof.
The premise of the book is that,
unless or until a vaccine for
the coronavirus is developed,
our means of controlling the spread
of infection depend on behavioral changes
and hence upon human psychology.
So in today's webinar, Steve will share
with us insights from this book
that uses social identity theorizing
to analyze the psychology
of the COVID-19 pandemic,
such as what encourages
us to come together
and support one another as a community
to help us through the crisis.
Before we dive in, I'll
quickly set the parameters
for today's session, which
will last 30 minutes.
I'll take my advantage of position as host
to ask Steve the first few questions
before opening it up
to questions from you,
the online participants.
So if you have a
question, please submit it
through the Q and A function
at the bottom of your screen.
And lastly, I'll mention that this session
is being recorded and will be available
on the CIFAR website next week.
So welcome, Steve. Thanks very much.
- Hi.
- To start our conversation,
what is the field
of social psychology, and why
is it particularly important
to understand identity and group processes
under the current pandemic?
- Okay, well, I'm not sure
whether I'm correcting you
or correcting myself because
you were citing something
that I said about behavior being
at the center of this
until we get a vaccine.
Actually, it's gonna be the center of this
even when we have a vaccine
because a vaccine does
not stop the infection.
People getting vaccinated does,
and people could be therefore
be willing to be vaccinated.
And the latest polling
evidence I saw showed
that something like 1/3 of people
are saying they wouldn't
take such a vaccine.
So there's this huge
behavioral question there.
Or equally if we discuss masks, same.
There's a lot of discussion.
Do masks stop the infection?
Well, the masks stop nothing.
Wearing a mask might.
And again, we're talking about behaviors.
We're talking about
whether people wear them,
how they wear them, how
effectively they wear them.
And most obviously, with lockdown,
lockdown as a policy does nothing
unless people agree to be locked down.
So right at the core of
every intervention we have,
including when we have a vaccine,
is dependent upon behavior
and human behavior.
Now through this pandemic,
there have been two very
different approaches
to human behavior and two ways
of thinking about the place
of the public in the pandemic response.
One is a very traditional view,
and it's a rather elitist
view, and it's a view that has,
at its core, the notion that human beings
are essentially psychologically frail.
We have a tenuous grasp on
reality. We are full of biases.
We have a tenuous moral compass,
which is easily thrown aside,
and that fragility is like exacerbated
under conditions A,
where we're in the group,
the group still further
undermines our rationality,
and secondly when there's a crisis,
and that's exemplified
by the notion of panic.
The notion is that, in
a crisis, people panic.
A Hollywood disaster film
would never be complete
without a scene of people running away,
screaming, waving their hands in the air,
and clogging up the exit.
So it's human psychology and the frailty
of the human subject which
turns a crisis into a tragedy
and, therefore, a public
or a real problem.
Now (chuckles) when you
look more closely at crises,
actually, that's not what you find.
What you find on the whole
is actually people behave
in a fairly restrained way.
They support each other,
they don't just look after themselves,
and they are rather resilient.
When it happens, every nation thinks,
"Oh, there's something special about us
because we've behaved in a
restrained and a supportive way."
So in Britain, we like to
think it's the Blitz spirit.
That's what does it. We're
different from the rest of you.
If you go to New York,
they'll tell you it's the New York spirit.
You saw it 9/11.
Actually, it happens nearly everywhere.
The reason why it happens is
that when we have common fate,
when we face a common
predicament, what we see
is the emergence of a shared
identity, a sense of us.
And that sense of us,
that extension of the self
to include others, has a
number of consequences,
including support for others,
coordination with others,
and therefore with others
working with others
when others become an asset
to us rather than a problem.
Actually, we become
psychologically resilient,
we become empowered, and
we become rather effective.
And what we've seen in this
pandemic in many countries,
certainly we saw it in the UK,
I think you saw it in Canada as well,
is that when that shared sense of identity
is understood, when it is
nurtured by leadership,
when it is scaffolded by policies
which bring people
together, then actually,
the public develop a sense
of collective resilience,
and that sense of
collective resilience is,
in many ways, the best asset
you have in a pandemic.
And so just to finish this comment,
for me, if I had a top 10
quotes of the pandemic,
I'm sure there will be lists
like that in Sunday magazines
in years to come, my number
one would be Andrew Cuomo,
the governor of New York, who said,
"It's not about I; it's about we.
Get your head around the we concept."
And what my work has
tried to do for many years
is to try and understand the we concept,
I call it social identity
but we concept will do,
and understand how it can be developed
and harnessed and how the
group becomes the asset
rather than the problem in a pandemic.
- Hmm, that's interesting.
Well, I'd like to pick up on the theme
that you mentioned around the role
of political leaders and suggesting
that they have a critical role
in fostering necessary group behaviors
and dealing with a health emergency.
What do we know about what's needed
in terms of effective political leadership
in an emergency situation like a pandemic?
- Well, let me start with the
concept of leadership itself.
And since you plugged the
"Together Apart" book,
also this week, we released
with my colleague Alex Haslam
and Michael Platow, a book on leadership.
So leadership is something
that interests me.
And when we look at traditional
notions of leadership,
they are, again, very
hierarchical and very elitist,
and they start from the premise that
what makes a great leader
is what sets them apart
from the rest of us.
The great leader has
these amazing qualities,
and if only you could
understand what it was.
If you could isolate this
right stuff and bottle it,
you would solve the problem of leadership.
Now the problem with that,
well, it has many problems.
First of all, it ignores the
fact that leaders, again,
don't achieve anything on their own.
They achieve it through followers.
So leadership which ignores
followers is an empty model.
Empirically, that notion
of, it is highly gendered,
great man leadership, has
been around for a long time.
Thomas Carlyle famously in
the, I think it was what,
1848, his book "On heroes
and Hero Worship" said
that history is effectively what great men
have done while they were on Earth.
Thousands of studies
trying to find empirically
what is the quality that shows leadership?
And they've all failed, and they failed
because, actually, they missed the point
that what makes a great leader
is what actually brings them
together with the group they seek to lead,
what makes them able to
represent that group,
speak for that group, shape
the understanding of the group.
So what the qualities that you need
in a leader aren't abstract or absolute.
It's more a matter of fit
between our understanding
of who we are and the leaders'
definition of who they are,
and leaders, we call them
entrepreneurs of identity,
are very skilled at telling a narrative
of the group and a narrative of themselves
which fleshes those two together.
And particularly what
you need in a pandemic
is you need a sense of shared identity.
You need to nurture that sense of usness.
You need to bring people
together to support each other
and actually to do the
practical things but also
to provide the psychological
support to take us through.
Now if one of the criteria
for being an effective leader
is to create a unified group,
then we see huge differences
between different leaders
and different places.
I think the leaders we've
seen who are effective,
so, for instance, Jacinda
Ardern, perhaps, in New Zealand.
Luckily enough, I don't live in England.
I live in Scotland, so we've
seen it with Nicola Sturgeon.
Actually, it's quite interesting.
When you name the leaders,
you see they have something
in common; they tend to be women.
But these are leaders who
have been very effective
in nurturing a sense of us
and in representing that sense
of us and also, of course,
in developing the policies
which support the
collective self interest.
But again, let me make a point here.
It's a simple point, but actually,
it's a rather inconsequential point.
In so much of our social science,
we start from the premise
that individuals act
in terms of individual self interest.
And the way to motivate the people
is to tell them what is in
their individual self interest.
The problem with that, again,
is it equates the self
with the individual.
It ignores the fact that
we can define ourself
in collective terms,
and it ignores the fact
that, actually, in the pandemic,
what is important is we
don't act for ourselves
as individuals, but we
act for the community.
So very simply, if people are acting
in terms of individual self interest,
a hell of a lot of people in this pandemic
would save themselves.
Actually, if I do the
cost benefit analyis,
I lose more by staying
in than by going out.
If you're young and you're healthy,
actually, you don't have
much to risk by going out,
and you lose a hell of
a lot by staying in.
I have a 16 year old next door who
is not very happy about having to stay in.
He suffers far more than I do.
So on the basis of
individual self interest,
your calculation would say go out.
But of course, at a collective level,
if you go out, you spread the disease,
other people get ill, and die.
So if you want to contain the pandemic,
people need to be thinking of themselves
in terms of that collective identity,
and by and large, that's what happened.
So for instance, I know the UK data,
there may well be data in Canada as well,
but it shows that,
actually, the main factor
which determines whether
people obeyed lockdown or not
was not their sense of individual risk.
It was their sense of communal risk,
their sense of community identity.
So again, understanding the we concept,
creating a sense of us, and
representing that sense of us
is absolutely central to leadership.
However, and actually, here, I could try
and show how much I know about Canada,
but I know nothing about Canada.
But luckily, Kate, you-
- (indistinct), yeah. (laughs)
- I read about Bonnie Henry,
and I loved her quotation
about "we're all in the same storm.
We're not in the same boat."
And the problem is it's all very well
to talk the talk of shared identity
and to talk the talk of an
inclusive sense of usness.
But of course, different people
within the national community are
in very different positions
and are affected very
differently by the pandemic.
It's opened up and shone
a spotlight on all that,
all our inequalities.
And therefore, part of
creating a shared identity
is not only to do it rhetorically
but to do it practically.
The practical economic
measures are, for instance,
supporting people so they
can afford to stay at home,
giving money to those who are unemployed,
giving monies to those who
are self employed, and so on.
And only if in practice
you create the conditions
for a shared experience
and a shared response
will you be able to create
that shared identity.
So as I say, it's a matter of rhetoric,
but it's also a matter of practical policy
which means that we're not
only in the same storm,
but we are at least to some
extent, in the same boat.
- Hmm.
Well, now that it's been over four months,
at least in Canada, since the
major COVID-19 restrictions
were put in place, we're
hearing more and more reference
to things like quarantine fatigue.
Is there evidence that
there are potential limits
to our psychological ability
to put up with restrictions?
- You see, this was a huge
controverysy in the UK.
And before we locked down,
we had people talking
about behavioral fatigue.
And they actually used
it to justify a delay
in lockdown in the UK, and that, arguably,
that could've cost tens
of thousands of lives.
Depending on how you calculate it,
you've lost about 8,000 lives,
from what I can see, in Canada.
We've lost about 60,000.
We've done pretty badly.
And this notion of behavioral
fatigue, if it led to a delay,
it's a big issue, okay?
Now when you look at
the notion of fatigue,
it is perfectly true that it is difficult
to sustain lockdown over prolonged period.
So the fact that there is
fatigue and compliance decreases,
I think, is not controversial.
What is controversial is what
is the root of that fatigue?
Is it an essential
psychological fragility?
And that takes me back
to what I was saying
about different psychological models.
Or is it something else?
So let me give you just one, I think,
very striking piece of evidence.
Again, I apologize, it's British evidence.
But I suspect it's the
same in different places.
In the UK, you found a difference
of a factor of six
between the most affluent
and the least affluent in
how often they went out
under lockdown, okay?
It's a huge difference in compliance.
But when you looked at motivation,
when you looked at the
psychological will to stay in,
there was no difference
between those groups at all.
The difference lay in
just basically the ability
to stay at home and put food on the table.
So there are a couple of factors
which are absolutely critical
in determining your ability
to go along with something.
One is, of course, the
information you'll give them.
People might suffer for a cause,
but if there's no cause to suffer for,
people aren't gonna suffer for it.
So if the messaging is bad,
and if the messaging suggests to you,
oh, well, actually, it's all over,
there's no danger, then
people won't comply.
So failures of government messaging,
we've seen that in the
UK, undermine compliance.
And the second thing is practical.
If people can't afford to stay at home
and feed their families, they won't do so.
So to my mind, the evidence
for the psychological fragility
is actually rather weak.
People showed incredible
resilience under lockdown.
Again, in the UK, I think it showed
that something like 44% of people
were suffering, but they still stayed in.
I think this has undermined those notions
of fragility and showed
collective resilience
when people worked together.
The problems, as I say, have
been those of messaging,
our government has been very bad at this,
and of giving practical support.
And so to talk about fatigue
being a psychological problem
in many ways, for me,
is the government blaming its own failures
on the failure of human psychology.
And I think that's a very dangerous
as well as very unfair thing to do.
- Hmm.
And so as I mentioned at the outset,
you've been advising both the
Scottish and UK governments
on how to encourage adherence
to public health behaviors.
In a previous CIFAR webinar,
we had one of our other
fellows, Tim Besley, who's part
of our Institutions,
Organizations & Growth program,
who spoke to the government use
of research evidence for policymaking.
This seems to be a
particularly political issue
in the UK right now.
Can you tell us why and
how you feel government
should use insights
from academic research,
both to guide the pandemic response
but also a post-pandemic recovery?
- So I think the
responsibility's always around,
and academics have got to be open
about the limits of what we know
and the certainties of our own evidence.
And clearly, given that COVID-19 is new,
and we're learning things
about it all the time,
both in epidemiological terms but also
in psychological terms,
there are certain things
we couldn't know yet.
We have some general
principles that we could apply,
and there, I think, one of the benefits
of psychological research is that,
on the whole, we do try and understand
like general processes of behavior.
So I can speak, for instance, to the role
of social identities and social norms
in behavior, and then I can apply that
to the particular types
of identities you draw on,
all the particular types of norms,
which is necessary to reconfigure
in order to get behavior.
So I think we have to be, as I say,
open about our own limitations.
And then from the
perspective of government,
I think there are two pitfalls,
one being to ignore the science
because the science, of course,
can tell you what the consequence
of particular actions will be.
But the other error, and I
think it's equally problematic,
is to claim to be led by the science
because if the science can tell you
what particular outcomes are likely to be,
what it can't do is tell you how much risk
should you or shouldn't you take
or how do you balance different
risks against each other?
Because that's a political question
or a value question, if you like.
And to claim that you
are led by the science
can sometimes hide the political choices
which I think is dangerous
and disingenuous.
So I think it's very important
to get the balance right
and to say the government
should listen to us
and governments should be
informed by the science.
But government should not
be led by the science.
And if they claim that they
are led by the science,
what they're trying to do is
to hide their own political choices
and therefore their
political accountability
behind the science.
And then, of course, what comes next
when things have gone wrong
is to blame the science
for the political choices that they made,
and I see signs of that
happening in the UK.
- Hmm.
Well, thank you so much, Steve,
for sharing your insights with us.
We've got just, I think, a
little under 10 minutes left,
so I'm gonna try and get
some of the questions
that have come in from our audience.
So the person has written in
that they find the most
challenging parts of COVID-19
is that the effects are delayed,
that there's a two-week delay period
between infection and symptoms,
and it's hard to know which types
of personal protective
measures are effective.
How has human psychology
adapted to dealing
with this kind of delay between
actions and consequences?
- Hmm, yeah.
Well, first of all, of course,
the asymptomatic transmission
issue we've discovered
is one of the most
significant issues of COVID,
and it's what makes it actually
such a dangerous disease
because a lot of people who don't know
that they are ill are going
out and shedding the virus.
That's one of the reasons.
People thought the major parameters were,
if you like, how infectious it was
and how many people it killed.
But the delay is critical
to the epidemiology.
It's also critical to issues like
why we should wears masks because,
a lot of the time, we
could spread the disease
without knowing that we
are spreading the disease.
There is a lot of research in psychology
about delayed gratification and
about temporality and so on.
I think also, again, actually,
when it comes down to
is clarity about understanding
and clarity about messaging.
And it comes back to, actually,
an even broader issue.
If you want to ask how
are authorities affected
and why people comply with authorities,
the literature tends to suggest
that it's not to do with
authorities being able
to punish you but you having a sense
of the authorities acting for you
and the authorities being on your side.
And so work on procedural justice says
if you want people to go
along with authorities,
in many ways, treat them
as you would a member
of your own group.
Treat them as a partner.
And part of doing that means
being open with people.
It means respecting people.
It means giving people all the
information that they need.
And one of the dangers
of this fragility notion
is that if you give people
too much information,
they'll panic, so we will
hide the complexities
from people 'cause they're not up to it.
My sense is that people are fully able
to understand these things as long
as a government has an adult
conversation with people,
respects people, and
provides a clear mental model
of the nature of the disease.
And so to me, this is
very much not an issue
of psychological limitations.
It's an issue of the problems
of the psychological government's models
which authority has,
and it's an issue of
clarity of communication,
giving us a clear mental model.
And part of that mental
model is an understanding
that we've got to act as
if we've got the virus,
even when we haven't.
And we've got to take the precautions
as if we could have the
virus, even when we don't.
And so I think those forms
of communication become an
absolutely central issue.
- Hmm.
Do you think there'll be a lasting effect
on social interactions even
after the vaccine's
developed and deployed?
- See, the paradox of that question,
I think, is, so there's all this debate
about how will society change.
Well, the problem is that if you think
that society's gonna inevitably change
in particular ways, you don't
fight for those changes.
You become passive, which
means that they're less likely
to happen, so that's the paradox.
Paradox is the more you
say this is gonna happen,
the less likely it is to happen.
For me, I look at it slightly differently.
I say, "What has this pandemic shown us?"
And I think it's shown
us two very clear things.
First of all, of course,
it's shone a spotlight
on inequalities, certainly
of race and ethnicity,
certainly of class, certainly of gender,
of generation as well.
It has shown us how pernicious they are.
It has shown us how murderous they are,
things that people knew before,
but it's become blindingly obvious.
And it's also shown us that the response
when people are angry
at those inequalities
is not repression; that simply
leads to social disorder.
It's to acknowledge,
address, and to change.
And so I hope that that vision,
both of the inequalities
and of the inadequacy
of a repressive response, will empower us
to struggle for a more equitable society.
The second thing it's shown
us in the (indistinct)
that's been at the core
of what I've been saying
is it changes our understanding
of the relationship
between the individual and the collective
in a quite profound way.
We've always been told the individual
is relatively rational, and
the group is bad for us.
So it's an idea that came out
in the period of industrialization,
basically because of
elite fear of the masses.
What we've seen in this pandemic
is the power of the group.
Now of course, that power
can be used in bad ways,
and we see that in pandemics.
At times, we see prejudice.
We see pogroms in pandemics.
But it can be used
positively like dynamite.
It can be a destructive power.
It can be constructive power.
I think understanding the
power of the collective
and the fact that the
collective is not less rational
than the individual is a profound change
for our social sciences,
and it raises questions,
of course, about the relationship
between the individual and the state.
And perhaps the state needs
to abandon its paternalistic
notion that people
are irrational and needs
the state to look after them
and change it to, if you like,
a notion that the state has
to scaffold the collective
self organization of people.
It's not a cheap option.
It's an option for budget cuts because,
actually, self organization
requires resources.
It requires funds.
But certainly, I think there
are some profound visions
we've had, but they are visions
that give us a notion
of what we want to get.
They're not gonna happen automatically,
and they're things that are
gonna have to be fought for.
- Hmm.
I'm looking at time, and trying to decide
if I can squeeze in one more question.
And it relates to the fact that
we often, we probably, well,
we all likely have
multiple overlapping kinds
of group identity and one of which
may be affiliation with
different political parties.
Particularly in Canada,
the US, and the UK,
political party affiliation
can be quite a strong element of identity.
Are there opportunities here
to strengthen solidarity
or to improve adherence
to public health measures
along political party lines?
- Here, again, I think leadership
is absolutely critical.
You can have polarizing leadership,
and, in fact, to me, what's
happened in the United States
is quite extraordinary.
One has a president who positions himself
as the anti-political president
and who is as an insurgent even in office.
The office of the president
of the United States acts
as an insurgent and
encourages people to act
in anti-state ways, encourages
people to violate lockdown,
encourages people to
protest and even be violent
against those who have taken
public health measures.
You can have a deeply
polarizing leadership.
I think you've seen it in
other countries as well,
so I think, for instance, in India,
we saw it to some extent in
the ways in which it was used
to pursue a Hindu nationalistic
agenda and to talk,
for instance, about corona
Jihadism, to blame Muslims.
So I think bad leadership in a pandemic
is really the worst of all
worlds and can divide people.
But where there has been
good inclusive leadership,
as I say, which goes
along with the measures
that bring people together, then yes,
I think we've seen extraordinary levels
of unity and extraordinary
levels of support.
So again, we sometimes think
of contexts automatically
changing human behavior.
No, it's the way in which contexts
are understood and made sense of.
It's the interaction between
the structure of experience
and leadership and structure of rhetoric,
which determines outcomes.
It's not inevitable.
It's not deterministic.
It's the intersection of the political
and the psychological which
answers those questions.
- Well, that is all the time
that we have for today, unfortunately.
Thank you to all who are
joining us from home,
and a huge thank you to
you, Stephen Reicher,
for sharing your insights with us.
Please visit our website at CIFAR.ca
to find out more about the series
and to view a recording of this talk,
which should be posted early next week.
- Could I make one final, final point,
- Please.
- if I may,
which is that the book which we wrote,
we wrote in order to be as
broadly available as possible.
So it is available as a free download,
doesn't cost you anything.
You can buy it as a paperback,
but it's a free download.
So if you go to look up "Together Apart,"
that's the name of the book,
you can have it for free,
and you can see some of the literature
and the evidence that lies behind some
of the things I've been saying.
- [Kate] Wonderful. Thanks so much, Steve.
- [Stephen] Thank you.